russian missiles have struck two
universities in the southern ukrainian
city of mikhailev the head of mecolive's
military administration released this
footage of the strikes
videos posted on social media
purportedly show the aftermath of the
attack according to the city's mayor at
least 10 missiles hit on friday morning
the full extent of the casualties is not
yet known but at least two people were
reportedly wounded
let's cross over to dw's imam walshas in
kiev what more can you tell us about
this latest attack on mecca live
well mikhail is really close to the
front line in fact it is also a front
line mikalayev itself is not occupied
yet but the region around it uh there's
parts of it that are occupied by uh the
russian army by uh prosecutors groups as
well and this city is simply under uh
basically constant shelling 10 missiles
early this morning
they fell
between other buildings they fell on two
universities we don't have
an estimate yet as to how many people
have been injured at least two people
have been injured but we do not know
more about
possible other casualties but this kind
of attack especially in the southern
part and in the eastern part of ukraine
has become
daily uh has happened on a daily basis
now
how are ukrainians coping with this
situation when you say this sort of
stuff is happening on a daily basis
well you know
as much as the you can see a form of
resilience when it comes for example to
air red alarms yesterday here in here we
had a series of arid alarms which lasted
one of them for several hours another
one for 10 minutes and you can see
people in the streets you know they just
stand to their everyday life they are
very resilient on that
account however when we get the news
that we got yesterday from vinicia with
dozens of people
killed in a residential
area by and you know by shelling
those news really affect people venezia
is a place you know where a lot of
people even kievans but also people from
uh eastern ukraine sensed their family
because they thought it was safer and
when places that are away from the front
line are being hit as is the case very
very regularly well people here really
feel that there's nowhere safe all
around the country
there are reports though
in the meantime that the russian
parliament's been recalled from holiday
for an extraordinary session to consider
unspecified government initiatives
is that the war in ukraine that they're
going to be talking about
we can safely assume that the war in
ukraine will be something that will come
up during this extraordinary session
vladimir putin is known not to give too
much of a head start to the parliament
when it comes to what is going to be
discussed but we also know that you know
the vast majority of the russian
parliament supports vladimir putin's
initiatives when it comes to the war in
ukraine we could
think
about the discussion of a possible
referendum in occupied territories when
it comes to their annexation or perhaps
even their annexation de facto will be
discussed it is something we'll find out
probably later today
dw's imam ashas in the ukrainian capital
thank you
that's we're going to dw's nick connolly
in kiev nick another devastating russian
attack what more do we know
well for now the details are pretty
scarce but i think the most important
takeaway is that this was an attack
basically in the morning rush hour just
before 8 o'clock local time and that's
been the pattern over the last few days
same in vinitsa yesterday and in you
know last few weeks we've seen attacks
on shopping centers and other civilian
targets
outside of the night time which is
normally the most dangerous in terms of
artillery and missile attacks obviously
during the night there's a curfew and
not many people about so seemingly no
attempt on the part of the russians now
to try and minimize civilian casualties
in these attacks and you know the
ukrainian government is adamant this is
a
tactic on purpose to try and so panic
this attack that we're talking about now
it comes a day after at least 23 people
were killed by russian shelling on the
central city of vinitsa hundreds of
kilometers away from the front lines
nick tell us the ukrainian president
condemned the attack on civilians as an
act of terror is that moscow's strategy
here to essentially bomb regular
ukrainians into submission
well that's definitely the take on this
here in kiev um whether or not this is
intended to uh you know hit civilian
targets or whether they're just not able
to hit
military targets independent of those
kind of collateral losses i think that's
a question later on for the war crimes
investigations that certainly are going
to happen at some point but certainly
russia is not changing its tactics and
is taking these losses for the course um
i think the other thing that's important
here is that russia's offensive in the
east or you know on the battle lines in
donbass is actually slowly grinding to a
halt those new ukrainian weapons sent by
the west are really helping to take away
russia's advantage to reduce the amount
of ammunition it has to throw at its
ukrainian opponents whereas in terms of
these cruise missiles these other
weapons that russia can uh
fire from further away from russian
territory that is still where russia has
the advantage and they're obviously now
increasingly using this to
attack ukrainian targets um i think the
most you know kind of crucial thing in
all of this is that this isn't working
for now the ukrainians are staying
behind their government there's no real
call from the population here to come
some kind of deal with the russians and
uh you know in rather than actually
getting people to ask zilenski to end
this in a hurry it seems to be building
morale and reminding ukrainians that
whether they are in this country they
are at risk of these attacks
meantime nick it's expected that
russia's state duma is going to be
recalled from holiday for an
extraordinary session to consider quote
unspecified government initiatives
what's expected
well there's been a lot of scratching of
heads lots of confusion seemingly lots
of the russian parliamentarians also
unaware why it is they're being called
back the speculation is that this is to
do with russia trying to somehow cement
its control over the bits of ukraine
that it's occupied since 24th of
february since the beginning of this war
um there was talk of referendums being
held in the same way that russia did it
in crimea back in 2014 or even maybe
dispensing with that and just declaring
these bits of ukraine as russian
territory which would then allow russia
to say this is our territory if you
ukraine or western countries supporting
ukraine do anything to try and reclaim
these territories which are obviously
recognized by no one as being russian
these are all you know ukrainian
territory as recognized by everyone then
russia would threaten nuclear responses
threaten to use its arsenal
and that would be maybe a kind of
negotiation position that russia would
use going into the next couple of months
as ukraine gets stronger as ukraine
receives more away western weapons so
lots of confusion there this is
obviously pretty typical for vladimir
putin who likes to keep everyone
guessing and uh obviously a lot of
attention here in kiev today to what
happens in moscow and the doom and what
it is they're going to talk about nick
connolly thank you very much
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
has condemned a deadly russian strike in
central ukraine calling it an open act
of terrorism several russian missiles
struck the city of venice hundreds of
kilometers away from the front lines
this footage shows the immediate
aftermath local authorities say at least
three missiles hit an office block and
damaged nearby residential buildings
police report at least 20 people were
killed including two perhaps three
children nearly 100 people were wounded
many of them are reportedly in serious
condition
now for alleged attacks on civilians
like in vinitsa or in the town of bucha
ukrainians want russia held accountable
in the international criminal court the
icc held a conference in the hague today
to discuss its approach to suspected
russian war crimes ukrainian
investigators eu officials and ministers
from over a dozen countries agreed to
coordinate their investigations around
20 000 cases are already open ukraine's
president zielinski asked the court to
open a special tribunal to prosecute
russian
leaders for jurisdictional reasons
the existing judicial institutions
cannot bring all the guilty parties to
justice
therefore a special tribunal is needed
regarding this crime russian aggression
against ukraine
a tribunal that will ensure the fair and
lawful punishment of those who started
this history of disaster and tragedy
which has become the biggest war in
europe since the second world war
well the dutch foreign minister one of
the hosts of this event says that a
special tribunal would be a vital step
towards a unified approach to
international justice take a listen
just like a climate strategy and a covet
strategy
we need an accountability strategy
a strategy driven by the universal
belief that all of us
all of us are protected by law
ensuring that all roads
lead to justice
now
and in the future
and speaking to reporters after that
conference ukraine prosecutor general
irna venektova held up a photograph that
appeared to show a child's body as she
discussed thursday's
airstrike
it is again the center of ukraine
today 20 people killed by russian
missiles including three children 52
injured by russian missile
including children and this information
we have every day from morning till
night till night to morning
we see more and more facts
facts of war crimes it's more now than
23 000.